hello
and we are live
good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
we are here with stormy
I am oh excuse me hang on a second I am
sorry
he is not stormy the bear today he is
stormed out
health
and we will do the opening credits and
then I will explain to you why I might
not be 100 with this today but and you
can all laugh at me but
we'll be back in one second
[Music]
right so I haven't told Harris this yet
but
I am um very hooked up on drugs right
now
um I'm on codeine and um ibuprofen and
something else and everything else
because yesterday I may have um either
herniated or slipped a disc in my spine
so
um I'm in
Agony so you're really enjoying sitting
down right now no weirdly I like lying
on my side lung on my side is good
um but sitting and standing and
everything is incredibly painful so um
but I've already told stormy the story
on why how I injured myself so I may as
well tell you young Harrison you sure
I'm in my mid-40s and I realized that
I'm you know getting a bit fat so um I
will do a bit of exercising and things
and I was chatting to my mate and I said
you know like I'm gonna start playing
I'm gonna drag him off soon to play
badminton with me I think it's badminton
I love badminton why don't we play
badminton let's let's get a call so I'm
like let's do that now if I'd have
injured myself playing badminton it
wouldn't be a very funny story you know
like I I would be you idiot no
I ordered myself a
um
badminton racket off Amazon
the Box arrived yesterday I bent down to
pick the Box up and my back went
foreign
I couldn't stand I couldn't I was like
against the wall going oh my God making
noises and the wife was thinking I was
going to a e
um it's just oh mate it's so painful
I've really got to start looking after
myself every time I moved I was awake
last night I was like
um but so um this is my legal notice I'm
very on a lot of drugs
so anything I do or say during this live
stream I am not legally liable for so
um at any point that I say anything that
you don't like
it's a drugs talking all right so I
apologize in advance for
every anything I feel quite drunk and
everything
anything
yeah like YouTube you can't you can't
demonetize me boy I'm not liable so
that's my legal notification so today we
were supposed to be doing a video
what's up stormy you've already laughed
at me once in that lady laugh at me
again
I'll die
I will I will literally if I can't even
pick up a box that I've been crippled
for a week how can I actually play the
game
oh if you get my age brother
yeah I'm up on Harris's recommended
oh God
tell people when we're on substances I'm
no well I am coming I'm on legally
obtained substances
um
um we were going to do our top five B
movies our favorite B movies but then
Warner Brothers dropped on us that they
have
going to be making more Lord of the
Rings movies so we decided first of all
we thought we'd just have a five minute
chat about that but then actually we
started thinking about it we were like
nice hmm
should we
next week will be our normal monthly
Stargate video so the weekend after that
we'll be
um
our top five B movies
swearing too much that's where there's
going to be swearing so
I'll snork that business yes Smeg Smeg
is going to be such a lot
um so Lord of the Rings movies guys
first of all what was your initial in
you know what what did you think when
this news fell so excited I'm just I am
the epitome of excitement rings of power
was probably the best show that's ever
been made and just licensing out all of
this IP is just the best idea I'm so
excited and they're gonna do an
excellent job no matter what
yeah I detected snark
Oh I thought he was confident but I'm
going to believe anything you say
because I'm hopped up on drugs no that
was that was sarcasm most definitely
sarcasm oh okay well I believe you then
in that case because I yeah I think this
is a risky thing I I think they're
insane I'm honestly down the title of
the video is are they freaking insane
because I think they might be what are
you still mean what was your initiative
my first reaction was oh my God
and then I took a breath and I go hmm
again
so it's
it there's so many factors and we don't
know anything we do the things we do
know the Warner said it's not going to
be a remake of The Hobbit or any of the
Lord of the Rings it'll be some sort of
offshoot or some sort of derivative
story that you know that like the
dunadine you know the story of Aragorn
and the Dunedin that's totally legit for
those series because in The Hobbit
you know Legolas was told to go find the
Dunedin this dude named Strider
it could been you know the 40 50 year
journey of Gollum through the Wilderness
before he gets captured by the ring race
and torture to Bear Doom or it could be
you know uh Tom Bombadil
it could be the Real Housewives of
hobbiton we just don't know
I would kill to watch the real live one
The Real Housewives of HobbyTown I
really would they could do the hobbit's
girlfriends and it'll just be all the
women because it'll be like Sam's Mrs or
Mom or something and it'll be their
story yeah right first question then as
we get into this it's not going to be a
reboot or a remake they've been very
clear on that very very clear on that
embracer only owns the film rights game
rights and Merchandising rights and this
is the Swedish company that actually
owns the rights that are now gone into
um a deal with Warner Brothers and new
line Cinema so they've they've been this
agreement Warner Brothers don't own the
writers this Swedish company called
embracing but they only own the rights
to The Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings
so my understanding is they don't own
the rights to submit the similar still
Marillion thank you and and things so
you make the notes of don't I mean I'm
very numb
except foreign
but other than it feels like there's a
hot poker in my back
ouch
um everything else is numb I'm like
it's the finger of the witch King in
your back all right hello back no
anything I'm not backside back
um so yeah
we know that exactly well we know that
one of the Rings of power's problems
were skirting around and the licensing
problems and the IP problems so they
were so there was it annoyed so many
people because they would mention
something but they wouldn't name it or
they would call it something slightly
different and they would skirt around
things that they didn't own but they
needed to mention for the story
are we going to see the same again with
any Warner Brothers project because of
Licensing problems that if they're not
remaking what they actually own
they're gonna have to do something and
they're gonna have to be a little bit
clever with the legal
aspects
what do you think Harris I I think
they'll do all right honestly of course
I with my whole intro aspect of things
that uh I'm trepidatious I I'm I'm
cautiously not optimistic but I think
that could be changed because Peter
Jackson and new line are involved and
obviously they they know Lord of the
Rings just as good as anybody making
Lord of the Rings right now they had to
do so much research just to make those
films back in the day and you know damn
well that they've thought of a hundred
ideas past the films pre the films this
happened I mean you know they have that
whole Golem story that you mentioned
earlier a minute ago Stormy in their
brain they have Andy circus's Gollum or
smeag will become in Gollum somewhere up
inside of their head they could make
that whenever they felt like that could
be great
obviously all these could be bad but
with with the right people with the
right team with the right
willpower I guess behind it it
we could get some good stuff I I'd love
to see some doing a day and stuff I mean
or or if you want to talk about
something like I mean Hobbit Housewives
would be pretty funny but
what about a political Intrigue of
Aragorn having to kill the rest of all
the Orcs the John campio show was
talking about that that'd be so
interesting the Orcs are essentially a
race of people that are still left yeah
I want to kill them all but are they
sentient enough where you don't want to
exterminate them so then it kind of gets
into like a political Intrigue while
still staying High fantasy so it's
almost Game of Thrones like for him I
don't know they could do a lot of
different things and they could do them
well but they're going to have to be
precise and and very pertinent with
every detail well if you're wanting to
have the rights to anything of Tolkien
you know The Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings is what you'd want because it's
the culmination of all the books
to come I mean you know Tolkien you know
wrote all of these notes and had all
these stories written down just to build
those four books
and so in the most of what he wrote is
somewhere peppered in
with um in either Fellowship Two Towers
Lord of The Return of the King or The
Hobbit you know even the cimorells are
mentioned in there you know only Frodo
carried around the last Light the light
available
scare the spider
and
um
so if you wanted to have any property
those are the properties you want to
have
you know because you it it's the
culmination of all of it
so there's a lot of I think there's a
lot of ways you can go
uh that that's also kind of part of what
scares me to a degree is that
even if it has to be based upon like the
films and not necessarily the books
itself the films are close enough to the
books we can still kind of explore some
stories Tolkien might have written down
in notes things like that
but
we're asking the question right now
should we do some sequels should we do
some prequels should we do some
spin-offs
that's already kind of jading me to a
degree because that's not what we should
be do that's what it felt like rings of
power was like what's the first thing we
can come up with that's not going to
screw up we already have
is that the mindset we're going into it
like just what's the first thing we can
do or what's the best thing that we can
do what's the most sensible what makes
the most sense that everybody's seen
Lord of the Rings we've seen the Hobbit
some people have seen ring of power you
can
I I don't know I I I worry about them
thinking overthinking it almost to a
degree so so so Harris you can was a
thought I'd had you you rushed upon it
and and it's it's real I think you're on
really solid ground here
so
I did a check on like the forums and and
discords and all this this last couple
days
and um
in in Twitter I did a pretty deep dive
on Twitter on some key phrases you know
um like binge watch The Hobbit or I you
know binge watch The Lord of the Rings
all weekend
there are very few instances of people
saying oh I went and binge re-watched
all of uh rings of power this weekend
you don't you do not see
a lot of that but you know in terms of
it must be ten to one at least a people
binge watching Hobbit Lord of the Rings
the Peter Jackson stuff as opposed to
rings of power I think at least
there's
now it's more difficult to binge watch
rings of power in one weekend because
that's that's 50 hours of content
thereabouts and there's have that for if
you watch Hobbit and Lord of the Rings
together you know even with extended
editions so but um
they def if you're going to spend their
time binge watching something they stick
to the movies
you're gonna binge watch the rings of
power though the problem is that you
will fall asleep repeatedly so
um you can't binge watch something if
you're asleep
so and it's bored and [__] in places I'm
sorry it is I wonder if
you know because originally you know
Amazon said they were going to
um
you know include Peter Jackson Peter
Jackson said yeah he was you know they
were in discussions and that's that was
the last we heard of Peter Jackson and
then that year a year or so passed and
there was no involvement at all
and uh the thing I like about this deal
at least Warner Bros oh yeah Peter
Jackson's our boy you know and you know
he's definitely a gifted filmmaker I
mean he's the only guy that I know in
Oscar history that was actually shooting
still shooting a film after it won best
picture
yeah no one else in Hollywood has done
that Mr Spielberg
I think my understanding is that Peter
Jackson
I know Peter Jackson has to be involved
with anything that Warner Brothers do
because of his contract going back to
previously
which is actually from what I'm told by
the guy I spoke to about this um he says
it's quite common that when a director
producer whatever goes into a big
franchise that it's there's this little
Amendment to the contract that's
relatively standard that if they then do
anything else prequel sequels whatever
that they have to be involved
um if you notice on the new Batman movie
with Robert Patterson Christopher Nolan
is actually an executive producer that's
because he had this contract that if
Warner Brothers do any Standalone Batman
project they have to involve him somehow
um it's the same with um Roland Emerick
threatened a few months ago that if they
do Stargate they wanna MGM have to phone
me because it's in my contract and
they'd have to be involved somehow my
understanding is it's kind of like a
first refusal kind of thing that they
have to sort of say do you want to be
involved and you can refuse
um and it's not necessarily stated how
you would be involved so it could just
be that Peter Jackson would come on as
an executive producer with on in name
only really yeah um or they could
negotiate and say you know what we've
seen what rings of power happened we've
actually seen what happened with the
first Hobbit film
um which didn't go great that you didn't
show run
do you fancy getting your teeth into
this
and Peter Jackson may or may not say
actually you know the 10 years the next
10 years of my life should be all about
the Lord of the Rings or he might go you
know what actually I've been there done
that we don't know what he's going to
say do we but but apparently that's the
contractual situation he has to be
involved somehow so at least we have
that reassurance well the reassurance or
it could be kind of what we're worried
with Brad Wright and Stargate as well
right now and not necessarily all
emmerich but Brad Wright is like
do we want him as a cons just a
consultant if if Peter Jackson doesn't
direct anything and he is the executive
producer if he does Kevin feige kind of
Lord of the Rings to a degree yeah
hopefully he doesn't do as many
spin-offs as Marvel is trying to toss
out there but
if if he were to take like an elseworlds
DC approach something like the Joker and
and you know that's just kind of like an
IP I'm not actually correlating like
that's what we should do just you know
get inside the head of a character and
go do something like that I just that
type of film where they take something
that's not necessarily a hundred percent
connected to everything that could be
fun uh you did make me think of
something when you said The Hobbit
because
the last Lord of the Rings things that
Peter Jackson directed was the hobby
trilogy
you leave a bad taste in a lot of
people's mouths it's not perfect by any
stretch especially compared to Lord of
the Rings because that's that's not
perfect in many ways
I think the the criticism of that comes
from how uh Guillermo del Toro was being
jerked around by the studios for was it
years
well yeah he was here
and he would you know he was set up for
years and he was also worried about
being signed on for
years in a row as well right right and
they were taking so long and so long so
he you know he exercised his opt out in
his contract and he opted out
and then you know Warner still had this
this schedule that they had to adhere to
I don't know if it's from the estate or
whatever so you know Jackson when he
when he did shot a fellowship he had
years of prep years of prep and he did
an intense prep
but he didn't have that you know for uh
The Hobbit and I'm wondering if that if
it was because if you notice the
desolation of smog and uh was a lot
better than Unexpected Journey right
because he's already he's you know
churning that over in his mind you know
and even the third move was much better
because he had time to prep in his head
you know the Unexpected Journey was just
like here you go all the sets are
already built
action and I think that that was a
hamper
and so
yeah and so uh going back to the chat
you know Crow and judicon was talking
about how they're worried about you know
WB and all the storylines they've done
keep in mind this is still going to be
new line managing the project new line
you know managed uh the original loader
series Lord of the Rings trilogy and The
Hobbit so that's the the unit within
Warner Brothers has taken charge of this
it won't be whoever is running into
Batman's
Fiasco these days people remember as
well the the pretty much all of the
people that were involved in the dceu
are gone
you know David that's right that's right
yeah yeah and he has cleaned house
um so we don't know what the DC future
is going to look like
we're gonna have to wait and see but
yeah I I don't think we can don't think
about what Warner Brothers had done in
the last 10 years when you're thinking
about this because David David says
let's come in and he has changed pretty
much everything it's a new era
need to give them a chance on that one
so so with that in mind and if we're
given chances
we talked about him just a second ago
could we get Guillermo del Toro to come
back and make a Lord of the Rings movie
because that would be one way to
immediately make me excited to have that
trusted of a filmmaker someone that that
is is that meticulous someone that they
already said If Peter Jackson's not
going to do Lord of the Rings this is
our guy and he just got fed up with the
BS on on the set in the whole production
aspect of things what's rightfully so
sometimes
if Warner Brothers and new line are a
whole new company essentially at this
point yeah and PJ's involved
can we get oh you know PJ was producing
the original Hobbit when Del Toro was
directed he knows the uh
the the the the the whole scene from the
concerning uh Bilbo the the dwarves and
the trolls
I mean those those those those scenes
were right out of uh del Toro's uh
drawings you know I mean he crafted that
whole scene you know new line parachuted
Jackson into to to uh the production you
know it
in the end but still on the greater
scope of things you know The Hobbit was
not The Fellowship of the Ring in terms
of quality but it was still a damn good
movie because people are going back to
my whole thing about binge watchings you
know people still binge watch uh the
hobbits not oh yeah rings of power as
much
no again The Hobbit made me go to sleep
as well
um The Hobbit started singing I left the
room and did something they were Dwarves
singing young man they were Dwarves
singing
there I didn't even Panic was having a
doily a panic attack Lord of the Rings
don't get me wrong
through the greatest movies ever made
Hobbit not so much
um Bob's got a good question there is
there any of the names that we need to
see attached I don't know if it's fair
to I mean guys if you can think of
people you'd want to be named off top of
your head that's great for more thinking
the writers of this particularly if it's
not going to be based or if if it's only
going to be partly based or inspired by
whatever whoever writes
these these films is going to be
important
um do you think this is one of those I I
really think this is one of those
projects that could get fluffed up
fleshed up that's not even a word I like
fluffing
Irish in the other day so we've got to
be careful about swearing but this could
get smegged up from beginning to end
before it's even before anything happens
if the right is wrong
well you you bring a great point up
there honestly just with with you saying
that if the person that is not if the
person that writes the movie is not
directing the movie I don't want to see
it with Lord of the Rings because they
need to be that meticulous and and
pertinent I I guess I've used those
words a couple times now but they need
to be that pertinent it's it's a
necessity for Lord of the Rings anything
talking and that's why rings of power is
just kind of it's wishy-washy because
they can't be pertinent with their
timeline they're just kind of like all
right well we're putting what we can
here we're putting what we can here it
looks pretty we're hoping for the best
yeah you know and I think that you
you're on to something there because
they had the most creative freedom in
the sets the Wardrobe the effects but
man they were really Stranglehold held
on
the storyline because they can only you
know they they can pull from all sorts
of books
but there's lots of things they can't
mention and all the books they draw from
all
Focus down to The Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings culminating in uh Return of the
King so it's real I mean
I can't imagine how frustrating it was
for the filmmakers to have that kind of
a choke hold on you know I mean it was
they're they're free with everything
else you know the actors had free reign
the award I mean and it was really good
you could tell they put the money there
but
I think you know Amazon made a mistake
of um
uh had of agreeing for so much money
agreeing to such a Stranglehold for
production
and I think that it was part of the
problem is because I
I think there's two big problems to
rings of power I don't want to get
bogged down on rings of power because
this is about this new movie
announcement but I think there's a
couple of big problems with power in
there the
the filmmakers the the TV mix were
basically learning on the job it's not
great and I think that shows in that all
the statements they've made about we've
learned so much from the first series
and I'm like how much did that first
series cost this is not an
apprenticeship my friends well
um
and I actually think they were trying to
copy the tone of the films too much
and it didn't work in the format of a
television show and it was maybe a
little too slow they may be spread eight
seven or eight hours worth of Television
over 10 hours and and they didn't get
the tone right and it was a little slow
and they've already said we've got to
we've got to increase the pace a little
bit in the next series now I actually
really enjoy doing some power In The End
by the end of it I thought it was pretty
good but I won't watch it again
ever because it's too slow I've already
watched Star Trek Picard I've watched
both episodes three times each
um because I love it rings power is not
that sort of show I won't watch it again
um but I did enjoy it I will watch the
second season but I will watch the
second season hoping they're gonna pick
it up a little bit
um I don't care how much Amazon spent
really it's their choice they want to
spend their money the only thing I care
about is that because they spent so much
money and wasted so much money I think
it's hampering other projects like
Stargate that I actually care about but
um but it was a good show in the end but
I do think like I said the first season
wasn't a practice run it's it's not good
enough really well to to to play Devil's
Advocate there and I I do agree with you
but to play Devil's Advocate nobody knew
who in the world Peter Jackson was
he had a a repertoire under him compared
to he did he he did you know but um
still he was a total unknown and people
I mean people tried to get um I forget
the guys that the producer's name the
the head guy at new line they tried to
get him fired for selecting Jackson
you know and who is this Australian guy
why are you I mean why is this guy Down
Under You Know The Frighteners I mean it
was okay I mean it wasn't worthy of
spending at that point in time the
amount of money they did hundreds of
millions of dollars
you know and to let him film all three
back to back and that was such a it was
crazy
but it worked perfectly that I think
that's if they're gonna do something
like that they have to do that again The
Hobbit shows why you can't not do that
again
yeah yeah he's from New Zealand by the
way not Australian well I'mma done that
oh excuse me
I'm a dumb uh Z
it I'm a dummy you are a dumb Zeke you
idiot see I have this little list of
curse words I made up that since we got
a little message on YouTube not to swear
as much so it's holy donkey toes
let's talk about Jake oh that was just
joking you know
oh dude I still can't believe it sent me
some curse words
um
before his project so his first film bad
taste in 1987 which he basically made in
his back Garden
again he was a camera operator and the
Muppet maker and everything then he did
brain dead and which is a stop-motion
movie which is Heavenly I'm pretty sure
one Awards
um
I mean you know he was in a slouch
Ed
silver Jack Brown jeans then The
Frighteners
which I love the brightness I thought it
was so good Michael J fox one of Michael
Fox's best and then straight to the Lord
of the Rings and then he's I mean since
King Kong District nine Adventures of
Tintin and then The Hobbit and then
mortal engines and that he hasn't done
anything since mortal engines which was
a massive flop
150 million dollars did you ever see uh
brain dead
I have seen brain dead yeah but bad
taster is my favorite I love bad toast
the the amount of stage blood used in
that movie was awesome
yeah just a very similar for um
um uh bad taste as well there's about a
bunch of aliens
and at one point a guy goes through the
head and then out the rectum of a alien
with a chainsaw very good
um in in
front Spirits in The Frighteners how
much they look just like the ring race
sorry stormy you won't know who this is
but that's very funny
George Galloway is a politician over
here in the UK it was very fun it's it's
the Hat as well isn't it
cheeky bugger you
um
uh yeah he was a politician that was not
very uh he was a bit outspoken we'll put
it that way
um sorry what did you say stormy I
wasn't I wasn't listening
oh I was just saying you know in The
Frighteners the dark spirits and The
Frighteners you ever notice how they
look just like ring race
yeah
it's very very similar to the flowing
caves the big long it was just really
hot and it was perfect the sergeant
major that sergeant major that I love as
well
um right so are we at risk of Warner
Brothers because I mean David's house
life came out a couple of months ago and
he basically said we're dropping a
crapload of projects we're focusing on
what has franchise capability and this
is the word that they seem to be
all over at the moment and franchise
capability so this is where they're
going with this they want to be able to
make a series of movies
Disney is pretty well known for
squeezing every last drop of blood out
of every project they have yeah the Star
Wars at the moment and basically Star
Wars has a new series every
[Music]
few weeks
it's ridiculous and the list of projects
are coming up is there a problem is
there a risk that they're going to take
a classic
you know movie of the the Lord of the
Rings a little bit The Hobbit and just
keep making the crap out of it until we
get bored and I actually say I think
this is a risk for
um
uh Harry Potter and a few other things
that they own as well is is that a risk
for the future that they're just going
to burn it well you know the the
the prequels to Harry Potter the the
magical world in the United States was
just abysmal I hate it and here here's
I actually I actually fell asleep
in the theater
on Premiere night watching the the first
prequel you know Fantastic Beasts yeah
yeah the the
uh imagine it just put me to sleep man
and it's focused on the Fantastic Beasts
you know
yeah it's I think there's a lot that
could have been there but I was totally
uninterested in the American magical
system you know I just didn't care
the second one was better the second one
was better but the third one is
rubbishing it's I mean everyone said
third one's better smart
um honestly Johnny Depp made the second
one for me I thought he was great
and is his legal issue stopped him
returning for a third
um but um I think it would have been
better if Johnny Depp is in the third
one but um maybe but um better with
Johnny Depp in the third one
I
I think mads Mickelson played the
character of Gellert Grindelwald better
but once you hire Johnny Depp to make a
character his own you have to keep
Johnny Depp in the character that he
made it's not at the same character the
the issue I think with Fantastic Beasts
three is it see I like Fantastic Beasts
one better than two just because it's
two's just two made me fall asleep uh
three
I feel like is a technical better film
the same way rise of Skywalker is a
better film than Last Jedi but it's it's
just not it's it's just milk toast fan
just whatever tossed at it you know it's
just like the most Wonder bread milk
toast kind of version of anything that
we can get we were seconds away from
having to evict you from this Channel
and man if you haven't saved yourself
then start turning out the rise of
Skywalker what is is this a threat
though for the Lord of the Rings or is
there a big enough Universe here and it
does seem that fantasy is on the rise
again that in popularity so yes
but Bob made a good point earlier in the
chat whenever he asked uh is is what did
he saying let me scroll up super fast uh
are there any names you'd want to see
attached yeah that's the exact same
question well that's the question Warner
Brothers is asking though but I guess
the the the pertinence there is are they
asking that for actors are they asking
that for filmmakers are they asking that
for the people they're putting behind
the camera and behind the projects
themselves or are they saying oh we'd
like a Gollum movie we'd like that
prequel Golem we'd want Aragorn doing
his uniday and stuff in in a prequel but
we'd also like Aragorn doing this
political thing after this are they
thinking characters wise are they
thinking actors wise are they thinking
the actual like people that will be
coming up from pen to paper I guess so
the the craziest thing I've seen in
fandom this week of you know fantasy
casting and Lord this lit the snort
house on fire was
um Brad Pitt as uh
as Tom Bombadil
and it was I guess maybe they watched
Babylon too many times or something but
Brad Pitt as Tom Bombadil
I think they're on Jay's minutes it
could be you know it might be I mean so
people are already talking about you
know oh who would be good for this who
would be good for that you know but
Brad Pitt
as Bombadil
I'm not sure about that
I mean Brad Pitt is anybody also
well no you need somebody like
old older not older for I guess because
Tom bombardo doesn't necessarily age you
need someone that could kind of be
some Brad pitterson age that's that's a
good point yeah never mind Brad Pitt
might be perfect things get pulled rude
to do it he's exactly the same age as he
was 30 years ago in um
and and honestly Paul Rudd would be a
great Tom bomba deal because Tom
bomberdale silly as a silly and there we
go camp cuss you know uh Robin Williams
made a perfect combin
I still miss him
oh so then
you just you just said a perfect time
bomba deal
could they license out the likeness of
Robin Williams to put him in the movie
I don't want them to do that but it's
going to start happening more and more
uh yeah yeah
too much in the honestly the the riots
that would be if they did something like
that like taken I mean they've got to be
I know they've done that a few times
with access they've been dead like 40
years well I mean you know
the amount of tickets they would sell to
I'd I'd be there day one and day two
yeah I mean they did that for uh uh a
moth Tarkin you know
yeah that's what I was thinking with the
because not Christopher Lee I always mix
it
the other one Jack Black
wait well well he can do serious stuff
usually be
well yeah he could do the theme tune as
well so you can do the theme tune it
should be great you would not fall
asleep with the divorce thing around Tom
Bombadil if I was just whatever whatever
role Tom Cruise wants at the moment
thank you Peter Cushing always makes
Peter Cushing and Christopher Lee
because they appeared in everything
together everything they just took
interns back in the day which one should
I be the vampire this time would you or
do you want to be the man you be the
vampire I'll be
um the Slayer okay and then and the next
one will swap okay
um which is just great um but yeah Tom
Cruise can do pretty much whatever what
he wants um yeah Paul Rudd is is Ant-Man
in the is the MCU Pamela but he does
other things he's also in the
Ghostbusters movies and so which is
great so um so I I
is there a risk and I'll just overdo
this they'll Disney fight or do you
actually just think as long as they make
a couple of good movies and they keep it
relevant
it doesn't really matter too much you
know a good film's a good film at the
end of the day and it's a big universe
we're talking about right
well you know Warner the the current
state or the the current you know uh
population or the of
Warner Brothers or new line the people
were running those companies really
haven't we don't have a history with
them of Disney buying anything I mean
they haven't
um we don't know where they want to go
with it they possibly could they may not
they may say well we're going to do
these few projects and they're going to
be prep they're going to be precious to
us or you know they could just you know
do the Jurassic Park slap it on a a
lunch box and you know and and Market it
everywhere
because Universal is just like they've
got such great properties Fast and
Furious Jurassic Park these huge things
they're just like here you go here let's
not think about anything here you go
they must have
Warner Brothers though must have a plan
for this right because there is no way
they've just watched what Amazon have
done with wings of power and gone well
that went well let's do that
um there's absolutely no risk of anybody
hating this there's yeah they must have
they must have seen what Amazon's
problems they must have
um and you know that everyone you know
that literally hundreds of thousands of
people decided they hated the rings of
power before it had even been filmed
so
they must have a plan
for this right
you know what it kind of makes me think
of is
they just oh and that don't don't brain
fart now uh it makes me think of
completely forgets what he's saying half
a second later uh but but it
it well Matt's not here to tell to shut
up so shut up Harris yeah give me a
second it'll come back to me it'll come
back to me what would you like to say
well Harris has a thing
this is why we don't do recognational
drugs before live shows this is just me
waking up I need them at nine o'clock in
the morning over there
um stormy oh oh sure yeah
sorry well Harris is high and Jay's in
pain I I will just say that
I don't think loader is very overrated I
mean the Lord of the Rings was
considered the best fantasy Trilogy of
the 20th century and some people would
say it was the best Trilogy period of
the 20th century so I'd have to disagree
with that Miramax to the rescue chilling
in a basement that is a horror story
uh
and chilling I did recognize your
sarcasm
I'm not on drugs
I like my other two compatriots are I
really am on drugs
um how about then the the still million
movie
is that a prospect I know I know this is
the book he didn't finish
but you could I'm not sure you can't
make a film out of it there you can't
make a film out of the silver alien yes
you could the similes yeah buddy you can
make a movie you can make three trust me
but okay it's something like that okay
yeah but it's like not thick and they
still made three [__] moves out of it
goes over a lot of time it would feel
much more like it would be high brow
fantasy that almost felt like highbrow
sci-fi which would be the issue that I
would have them making a film rule
all right okay if that makes sense
but I I thought of what I was thinking
you're ready good yes we are prepared
that would be amazing we're just talking
about David zazlov right and obviously
we just talked about
PJ will be involved yes but we know kind
of zazlov's mind and things right now
and we're talking about their whole new
company essentially under zazlov and he
just did this with James Gunn and the DC
Universe and you know you know we're not
going to dive too much into that but
about what uh everything you said
Futurama is the greatest sci-fi thing
ever made I didn't say that I just said
it was wonderful I did say it was
wonderful
uh
uh but I so James Gunn tweeted in the
past I think week or two that he was
hired to write Superman Legacy over six
months ago which caused a little stir
because Henry Cavill was hired to be
putting Black Adam within that amount of
time so they kind of lied to Henry
Cavill and we're like okay we're gonna
put you in here just so people buy
tickets for Black Adam
I understand but come on you you just
toss it under 50 000 out there so James
Gunn was hired six months before being
announced as the people to actually
run DC
has Peter Jackson been in talks with
Warner Brothers since Amazon announced
that hey we stopped talking to him or
since we all kind of realized Peter
Jackson's been kind of put on the back
burner did zazlov say hey we want to do
this
so he started talking to him six eight
nine months ago whatever it may be
and kind of like James Gunn with
Superman is he already writing something
so maybe zazlov doesn't necessarily have
to worry about
maybe he's not so worried about figuring
out figuring out exactly what they want
to do with the franchise because Peter
Jackson is going to do it for him and
he's given him a certain amount of time
to do that I'll I'll admit something now
that I wasn't going to admit it makes
you sound like a dumbass
um
I knew about this six months ago and I
didn't believe it
so so yes bastard oh excuse me so that
just means zazlov is New York
putting it in PJ's hands that's good
so
um right so one of my sources
um
something for the G thing thank you very
much Bobby sir
um
uh one of the people I do speak to and
he does work for Warner Brothers he says
he heard this rumor
um
in uh September
that they were already talking to Peter
Jackson he is the one that's told me
about that that
um it's definitely he didn't know for
sure to be fair and we chatted about it
and we agreed that it probably wasn't
true because I said does it make sense
why would they but that was then
he heard they were going to do a remake
um and and and that was the bit that
that sort of you know Chinese Whispers a
little bit I think
he heard they were gonna do a remake and
we agreed well that doesn't make any
freaking sense why would they remake one
of the most popular movies of the last
30 years
um so we agreed it probably wasn't true
so I didn't tell anyone
um
as it turns out that's not but
apparently they were talking to Peter
Jackson six months ago
you know and no one makes these kinds of
deals without some idea of what they're
going to make
you know there's got to be a free debris
some sort of script synopsis or
you know that you know they've gone
through pitch meetings already
well you know if we if we give you these
rights or whatever if we say these right
what do you want to do with it
you know because we own the rights and
so it's going to look bad on us if you
totally you know uh jig it up
and so
what are you gonna do so you know
they've already gone through these
meetings probably you know like you said
for the last six months and it's been
progressing progressing progressing and
now they got to the point says oh that's
good that's good that's good
let's let's put our signatures on it and
then let's tell the world so the tools
and the Fanboys can all get on board and
scream about it at each other probably
well from what I've been told like I
said by the guy I talked to he just says
the only problem has been the reason why
it's been announced now is because the
deal with Embrace has been finalized
that's why it's been agreed now up until
now it was figuring out what that deal
would be and Grace who wants their money
Warner Brothers want their money with it
being a front fee or would it be running
on the other account I'm being told that
there isn't a very large upfront free
within embracer and that the embracer
are not getting a large upfront fee from
Warner Brothers this is a partnership so
embracer will get the back end and and
that's partly because Warner Brothers
don't have the money to do that but it's
as took a couple of months to um
to get that deal going if you just
[__] writing about I swore again I'm
in so much pain Futurama man got to have
a conversation you gotta look up right
above it they're going to do a Futurama
version of Lord of the Rings
uh just to talk
why not um there'll be a uh what's the
the Robot Chicken I do a Robot Chicken
of it or something just to just to like
get advertising you know like ah God
damn it
um
yeah yeah but um but but yeah I I
so the yeah the legal stuff's gone on a
little while in front with him and um
I'm sorry I didn't tell you stored me
six months ago but I didn't think it was
true I'm sorry
so
I guess snork rabbit you
I get hit I get told lots of room so the
thing is though and I
obviously even if it's true stuff
doesn't get picked up and then but then
it just looks like I'm making crap up so
I have to be a bit careful what I'm
saying don't say but then some stuff
just get I get over excited about and I
just I do a video about and then I'm
like afterwards I'm gonna always do next
time
um anyway if you were Amazon and if you
were um in charge of who you know the
the guys running the rootings of power
oh irritated to you right now
well a lot
yes but also isn't
Amazon kind of starting this obviously
they they have rings of power and they
they started the spin-offs or whatever
but aren't they making the war of the
rohiram film how's that planned
everything the animated uh Lord of the
Rings war of rohiram film planned
everything because isn't Amazon making
that and that's got to be like I don't
know where that fits legally at all
honestly
because it's Amazon's film if they don't
remember correctly
as I am as I understand it
is that the animated thing they do yeah
it's the anime version kind of like
Witcher did their night night of the
whatever it was which was actually
really good uh much better than that
live actions sequel spin-off that they
did but the war for the rohiram is kind
of like it's not the founding of Rohan
it's it's but Rohan was rohiram back in
the day something of the sorts am I on
the right lines for me
doing a cinematic release and calling it
TV
it could go straight to Prime if it's
just animated that's what the witcher's
anime thing did or they could release it
because it's the lord of the freaking
Rings I'd say release it I'd go see it
yeah but then I think that's gonna step
on what Warner Brothers
are actually sorry this Swedish company
embracer they have the movie rights
specifically the movie writes but that
did happen after rings of power and
Amazon got their rights to do everything
so is there some weird gray area I I'm
honestly not sure I'm just kind of
opening I don't think they're often with
this is there are lots of little gray
areas and the thing I reason I I think
the biggest threat with this if they do
something different is that they're
going to have to do what like I say
earlier what rings of power did and
they're gonna have to dance around a lot
of the
a lot of the legal issues with whatever
they produce
and I I don't think most
most viewers will care I watch the rings
of Power Man and I don't notice all
these little dances they were doing I
only found out because either stormy
told me or I watched a video going that
shouldn't be like that because this
battle didn't happen then it happened
and like people that really really care
about the material
um I I don't know the books
I can't believe stormy hasn't pushed his
stack of books in at any point I've been
waiting for it they're they're in a
shipping crate dude I'm sorry yeah I
thought they would be they're 808 miles
away and I feel every mile
um but but you know what I mean but but
but I'm going back you you're you know
I'm reading here that warbrew hear him
is new line
not
um not Amazon not Amazon
really
um
the Rings the war over here I'm in
upcoming anime fantasy film directed by
Kenji kamayama from a screenplay by
Phoebe Gittens and already Papa Giorgio
based on the novel Lord of the Rings by
J.R Tolkien produced by new line Cinema
in Warner Brothers animation with the
anime production by solo entertainment
there you go then so yeah that's and
that's it probably will be a cinematic
release then because
um they've got the rights to it so yeah
183 years before the events depicted in
Lord of the Rings The Two Towers
so this then leads into then that they
must have whatever that contract is with
the rings of power like you said with um
sorry with this company like the Lord of
the Rings and The Hobbit
but we said that there was something to
do with derivative works
yeah this would come into that right so
that does give us a bit more of a hint
on where they're going with this thing
they're already doing it they're doing
it with the cartoon that we know about
so that's probably what they're going to
do with the movies isn't it they're
going to do something similar along
those lines again there'll be something
derived from something that happens
right in The Hobbit the Lord of the
Rings right so in that case so they're
going to be jumping all over the time
frames they could yeah oh yeah yeah it's
so uh a friend of mine I don't know if
you guys remember the TV show is the
soap opera back in the day called Dark
Shadows
yeah
well uh a friend of mine
um he did a lot of the novel he did some
novel novelization of those of of that
he was using derivative works of the
original Dark Shadows to tell Original
Stories and he just you know and because
um the the production company was uh
giving him permission and oh yeah we
have the rights to this and you and you
so therefore write a derivative work of
this and so he wrote derivative works of
Dark Shadows under that license for that
Series so that kind of is how it's I'm
guessing it's going to work here in
other you know make creating derivative
Works off of someone else's work once
you get the license for that and you
have permission to do derivative works
up pops uh the war of the rohiram and
who knows
yeah Lord of the Rings and want to talk
about the Lord of the Rings covers
hundreds thousands of years
so
there's lots of lots of things that gets
mentioned one or two pages here and
there that I mean don't get me wrong one
or two pages
tolkien's one or two pages you know he's
like he can spend half a week describing
a leaf but um things that he mentions is
for him in passing that could become an
entire series of movies so they will
Disney fire them and create a million
projects
um
do you do
I just say that I I put a poll on the
channel earlier just to say
um do you want Warner Brothers to create
this
um I'll just double check what the
score's now but it was basically 60 of
people were saying no they don't want to
see it
um I'll tell you exactly 58 said no
simple question do you want the Lord of
the Rings movies from Warner Brothers
more Lord of the Rings movies from porno
Brothers 42 say yes 58 they know is that
a surprise
I wonder what the results would be if
you say if you exchange the you should
write another poll exchanging Warner
Brothers for new line Cinema to see what
the results are because maybe a lot of
people have no idea that Warner Brothers
owns new line
yeah
or maybe you've got I don't know I mean
it's interesting you know it's people
are very protective the fans are very
protective over Lord of the Rings and
Peter Jackson
I I bet you the poll would be different
if it was worded like if Amazon's not in
control of making more Lord of the Rings
movies
[Music]
vice versa it comes down to do you want
to see more Peter Jackson Lord of the
Rings movies I think that would be a
different story again right yeah so
just before we go because I'm in agony I
won't keep you on today I feel I feel
bad for you dude you don't have a choice
so when we
um uh get this
how much crap do you think we're gonna
have to
Wade through from certain people that
Hate Everything regardless of what it is
um
Peter Jackson being involved is they're
only saving grace that that might save
wading through some crap
but I assume we're still gonna Wade
through some crap
oh the the crap is already there
yes
you know
within minutes
the within minutes the zip started
yeah another made of wood like you said
I honestly think if they get Peter
Jackson regardless of how they get pizza
Jackson involved I think they need to do
what they did before with the first Lord
of the Rings movie and Peter Jackson
kept doing all these little
um videos and stories and photos did he
put like a photo diary or something
together didn't he you know they need to
start doing letting him do little little
Tick Tock videos or anything yeah
because that's one of the things I think
was a problem with rings of power so
that Amazon is so freaking secretive
yeah
I think they should have been telling
people from the beginning and letting
the creators talk about it and do all
you know and I think they would have if
they'd be more open I think they'd have
gone away but if for me let Peter
Jackson do that again from the beginning
it'll build
if you remember you know that this is
going back
23 years ago that Peter Jackson had
these things he he shot little tiny
films called production Diaries
that's it that's what he did yeah and it
was
what is he doing he's showing the magic
behind the screen you know even when he
shot
um King Kong Jack Black was you know he
did a um
Jack Black talked about how nervous he
was just showing his wardrobe before the
movie opened he says are you sure you're
supposed to film me my wardrobe
I mean I mean it was it was not Jack
Black being Jack Black and it was like
dude are you supposed to be filming this
he was actually concerned that
you're showing my wardrobe me in full
you know full kit when nothing's been
released and he was kind of because
there's you know another films this
that's that's a No-No and it's in your
contract
you know don't you know no spoilers but
here Jackson was man well here's how
we're going to do this shot and he I
mean he's like I mean he really did a
master's class in filmmaking with these
little video diaries you know well today
we got 4 000 horses and we're going to
run them across and it was never done
before and I think if you've got um
the original DVD release of the extended
versions
or the special editions rather you've
got um those those uh production diary
videos are actually an extra feature on
the DVD set
yeah I've seen that soon and now we've
got Tick Tock like I said we've got
YouTube we've got everything else that
would allow him to do it in a way that
would actually generate income as well
he'd get millions of views on YouTube
um and generate excitement and blah blah
but they also you can do it in
in clever ways it doesn't give away too
much of the plot and things and you can
you can just have him talking about
making the armor or doing things or some
of the shots that he's having to do and
some of the complicated some of the
difficulties of well we've got this shot
and we've got this in this album because
of Blair
um and and and people and I love that I
just I hope
but I'll tell you my hopes for um the
Lord of the Rings for one I hope they
don't do too much CGI I think that's a
massive problem with a lot of projects
nowadays and and I hope that if Peter
Jackson comes into this they let him
create a movie that he actually wants to
create with his biggest his bigatures
were amazing yeah like build sets build
things and you could tell in Amazon so
much of it isn't just in front of the
green screen it's it's frustrating the
in the rings of power sometimes CGI is
one of the big reasons The Hobbit didn't
do as well it just it there's uncanny
valley where there shouldn't be
yeah just make up somebody
yeah yeah exactly so let yeah so I hope
I generally hope that
um oh dear God and um and I generally
hope Peter Jackson is sorry but my main
thing is I hope Peter Jackson is it very
is is in charge of where the story goes
or at very least somebody that is
um as in love with the project some
somebody needs to be in charge of this
they need a Peter gun for the DC they
need somebody that's going to make all
this and keep a coherent and make sure
that they don't go off in lots of
different directions and
because honestly I can't listen to
stormy complain if they make silly
mistakes in this and you know I will I
mean I'm already getting a headache from
it
um
um but what do you think that's what
what are the things that you
really
are hoping for this or what are the
fears what are the things that you may
be nervous about
if anything you know I really don't I
mean I had trepidation with rings of
power uh I was willing to give them a
lot of slack you know because I hadn't
seen the finished product
but I know what new line and Peter
Jackson can do even under strenuous
circumstances like the director quitting
in terms of The Hobbit and Peter Jackson
having to rush in and get Unexpected
Journey out
I don't have any trepidation it's like
okay cool you know Jackson will give us
something that we've never seen before
you know and I do hope he keeps the
production Diaries going you know as as
like he's done in almost every I think
he actually did production diaries for
mortal
Immortal engine maybe
um
but I hope he keeps that up going
forward for the fans
and uh
I mean for as a as a a Tolkien total
total fracking Fanboy
um I did enjoy rings of power
it could have been better
could have been better yeah I know
hopefully the second season will be
hopefully the second season will be a
bit more what we wanted
um
David I'll get it right by the fifth
season you never know
um Paris you got any hopes or fears on
this project I mean kinda I guess what
we've already kind of covered more more
so in the sense where
I'm hopeful that they focused on the
filmmakers and particularly particularly
the writer directors not the writers and
the directors I want writer directors
for this okay
in here
I guess and then I guess it's just
dependent upon where their mindsets are
making it and and
we'll see over the next couple months
and and as we get more and more info uh
I I I'd like for Peter Jackson to be
able to actually give us little inklings
of what's going on because he got that
from George Lucas doing Phantom Menace
and and attack of the Clones that a
whole different time period for now
everyone's trying to hide everything
going on set so much and leaks come out
like you know yada yada we know
obviously but
back then
Peter Jackson saying look at our armor
look at what's going on look at these
horses so many people are on set this
day
uh George Lucas two years prior to that
was doing fan contests that hey vote on
what droid's gonna be in the next movie
stuff like that he'd had a little camera
very specific camera he's not showing
you everything on set but he's showing
you like the blue and green screens
they're using and like maybe somebody
fighting a little bit for that day
and it gives people hope and
encouragement for the film like okay
this is gonna be there this is cool this
is interesting it's already got my
involvement I'm gonna go see it when it
comes out yeah Lucas had this one one
little
um production diary and it was a
collection of all the times that the uh
the onset R2D2
malfunction you know it would fall off
of the stage it would like tip over you
know it just freeze or something would
go and and he just turns to the camera
and says I have bad Droid Karma
Nothing Cut end but going back to Attila
the finishers a question what loader
book should we adapt into a movie
all of them what's wrong with you all of
them yes
man
the thing is man the the tradition now
is this way for each book would have to
be at least three films
a million books
I know I mean like The Hobbit could have
done well as a dude as a diligy or a
duology or however you say it
not a trilogy The Hobbit book is that
thick it should have been one film oh
anyway how many pages
but um right guys that's I think so oh
what moved funny then again yeah I I
think
I gotta be honest I I didn't see this
coming even though I was told repeatedly
that it was coming
um
well hey let's see what happens I I do
think
we're getting a lot of fantasy projects
so it kind of makes sense and Warner
Brothers this is definitely the way
they're going so we're gonna have to
listen to listen to a lot of people
saying this is going to be a woke mess
and this is going to be this and that
and it's going whatever but
at the end of the day
if Peter Jackson gets involved and we
get the right people involved I think
there's a big enough University that we
could get something
pretty exciting so let's see what
happens oh uh to answer Kevin McCabe's I
think uh sir gwain in the Green Knight
uh that came out a couple years ago with
Dave
Patel Patel yeah yeah yeah uh excellent
excellent you know and Tolkien is known
to have the best translation to English
of certain uh sir Duane in the green
light
excellent I own that movie I love it
yeah
it took me a year to watch it and I I
love it ever since
oh by the way the Hobbit was 304 pages
so we're talking about one film per 101
Pages more or less
Fellowship of the Ring was
479 in comparison
and it only had one movie
right
I'm Gonna Roll the trailers and then
we're gonna say
we're gonna wrap it up all right so one
second nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at nineshavrons.com
also has some amazing merch get yours
today and show your support at
side-track.com
I was going to like reading footage up
in my mouth everything that I thought no
better not exactly I'd be in pain if I
did you know Harris looks like Legolas
with like a goatee have you noticed this
between
I'll tell you about talking about
fantasy and Legolas yeah Carnival rope
have you guys started to watch that the
new series I have not seen season two
I couldn't get into season one oh I I
loved it I thought it was great and I
mean I'm enjoying season two even more
um so yeah I've really enjoyed it at the
moment the first two episodes dropped
I've seen the first three episodes uh
it's good really enjoying it
um it uh too far the first series did
take a little bit of getting into
but by the end of it it was great but
yeah yeah Matt The Dean Madison
hey man we'll see him next week I'm sure
so next week guys we have our monthly
Stargate
um watch video
um I normally do a weekly Stargate watch
video and um I forgot this week and then
I did my backs over there
um I'll do it next week so next week
we'll be talking Stargate we will
potentially have a bit of a review of I
think we're up to season five I think
we've done one two three and four
um but also we'll have a bit of a chat
about some of the News That's dropped
over the last couple of weeks and we'll
just talk Stargate a little bit and then
the week after we will do maybe unless
something else comes up our top five B
movies
of all time so I'll get those in
um just before we go as well I think I
am going to turn the memberships off
YouTube I
um I don't want to give YouTube
um any more money than I have to and
YouTube do take a third of all the
membership money so Harris a third
you'll remember a third of them will go
straight to Youtube
um a friend uh well not a friend but a
fellow YouTubers recently got his
channel demonetized and he is the most
Pleasant guy you'd ever meet um actually
we share a lot of subscribers so
um other people know that um
Egotastic fun time really big Channel it
talks a lot about um
story We Do
okay so you guys know I moved to New
Mexico right there's a huge dust storm
right now I can barely see across the
highway
is this a normal thing for Las Cruces
I don't know if you guys can hear it or
not but you know
but holy donkey toes is it a train wreck
outside
it's one it is
I'm sorry it was it was the the I've
been in startling weather for the last
four days and that's I've never been in
that kind of a that's bad Matt's gonna
have to make a graphic that has like a
little rubric key that shows what words
what for stormy
so yeah I had holy donkey toes frock
Gorham Frac snork zeep and Jack
[__] frack
uh it could be fun fact you know once
the the TR you know ones that you know
the the present the future chance the
past tense I think yeah
smeg's perfect it's Smeg you Smeg off
smegging hell for Smeg sake
um oh dear Smeg and it just goes on and
on smegging is the greatest
I didn't want to use that because of
yeah masculine cheesy kind of reference
yeah I don't I don't need that type of
cheese what what are you doing no thanks
and it's a fridge no anyway there's some
company started making selling smack
fridges over and it's like Norwegian or
something and we're all that going from
what
the BBC have started making that would
be I was so confused chick cheese yes
yeah I I don't know if Jay understands
what we're referring to as smegma here
yeah you do man juice
no women juice women juice no my God
it's not just Google it later but don't
do it while you're kidding you will
explain it off cam trust me this country
smegma is is when ladies get very very
happy
and they create a lady juice we're gonna
get in trouble again
no no
I'm going to turn the memberships off I
think because of YouTube but I'm going
to create a patreon account
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start putting our videos on patreon and
I'll share this week so you'll actually
get to see our videos that I do at least
a little bit before YouTube and I'll do
some giveaway and things because
if I'm gonna ask you for your your money
which I need because I'm going to have
four days a week from next week
um to do YouTube videos
um I need to
give back to you guys as much consumedly
possible so that's what I'm doing but
four days a week it's the Dream It's the
dream people
um and uh and I get to do that because
of you amazing people I get to do that
no no small part because of YouTube as
well and giving so much of your time to
talk rubbish
um
women are not making a nasty you're
right Shelley you're right
some women we held it together for
almost an hour and then we went down the
juice tree
one way to remember
yes yes
the expanse is coming back utility I
will put money on it
one way or another uh right guys so
thank you so so much I'm sorry that
occasionally I have Winston Payne and
I'm a little paler than normal
um but you know where these things
happen but I'm still here for you and do
you guys by the way before we leave do
you guys want to know that man United
scores
sure
yeah two now we won that's our first we
just won the carabao cup final so that's
the first one
golf club and United won it again not
only am I in pain I've missed the Man
United game for this because I love you
guys that much so thank you so much
you're double fracked double fracked no
no I'm no I'm I'm singular fracked my
back's fracked but man united won
so I'm unfracked but you didn't get to
see it
I didn't get to see it
it's freaking awesome and if I had to go
to the pub to watch it anyway and I
can't because I can't walk
um and this t-shirt isn't just a
beautiful t-shirt it's I'm actually in
my pajamas and I tried to take this off
to put my Sidetrack t-shirt on and I
couldn't
so I'm I'm messed up so what you're
saying is next week when we're talking
Stargate you're gonna be cosplaying the
top half of a person and laying on your
side like a French girl for the entire
time huh yeah I'm gonna put the laptop
on the floor and I'll be sideways like
that and I'm like no I'm probably better
by then I'll be fine anyway guys thank
you so so much everybody has been
amazing as you always have been thank
you so much for coming to see us and we
will see you next week for our Stargate
live show love love love
I have a good one bye enjoy the snow if
you're in California apparently not in
the San Fernando Valley though
the one place gotta love it see you
later guys British pants American pants
[Music]